ganz herzlich willkommen hier bei bild
sagen sie uns bitte was genau passiert
in diesem zulassungsverfahren also mann
begleitet da muss man sich das
vorstellen die klinischen tests die
jetzt noch laufen und schaut sich die
ergebnisse immer wieder an alle paar
tage zu akzeptanz für das review
verfahren gehört dass zunächst daten aus
nicht klinischen untersuchung zu dem
stoff und daten aus früheren klinischen
prüfungen gesichtet wurden diese daten
waren zufrieden stellen zu dass die
akzeptanz dafür diesen rollen
das bedeutet aber auch dass das sprechen
der unternehmen signalisiert hat relativ
schnell innerhalb der nächsten wochen
und vielleicht monate gute daten zur
wirksamkeit und sicherheit des im stoff
produkt aus größeren phase drei
prüfungen nachzuliefern
damit besteht eine gute aussicht dass
das bewertungsverfahren zum positiven
ergebnis zu einer positiven nutzen
risiko bewertung führt allerdings bleibt
abzuwarten was die glücklichen
wirksamkeits und sicherheitsdaten an
mehreren zehntausend probanden ergeben
wird die wenn man davon aus dass jetzt
die prüfung positiv verlaufen dass
dieses verfahren dieses prüfung
zulassungsverfahren positiv
abgeschlossen werden kann
ab da bis zur auslieferung sozusagen in
die arztpraxen wie lang dauert das
wenn es jetzt sozusagen das goal gibt
okay ihr könnt produzieren ihr könnt das
vertreiben den impfstoff wie lange
dauert das dann noch bis wir das
medikament in den arztpraxen haben
es dauert monate man muss sich vor augen
führt zunächst muss das
bewertungsverfahren und
zulassungsverfahren abschluss kommen
die vorausberechnung der ema besagen
dass dies vielleicht anfang nächsten
jahres sein könnte
im moment wird ein konzept zur
vermischung geschmiedet vom
bundesministerium für gesundheit im
bundesländern
dem paul-ehrlich-institut im
robert-koch-institut vielen anderen
und natürlich muss priorisiert werden
gerade daran arbeitet im moment die
ständige impfkommission
in deutschland zusammen mit den
deutschen ethikrat und der leopoldina
also insgesamt blicken wir darauf dass
wir hoffen dass im nächsten jahr erste
zulassung von impfstoff produkten auch
dieses produkt da sein werden die
vorhersagen können erst gemacht werden
wenn tatsächlich dazu sicherheit und
wirksamkeit vorliegt was nicht der fall
ist
danach muss priorisiert werden es müssen
erst person geübt werden zum beispiel
die besonderen risiken ausgesetzt sind
und dann kann sukzessive im laufe des
jahres weiter geübt wird also das würde
dann dieses konzept zur vertiefung dass
sie angesprochen haben beinhalten
praktisch wer kriegt den impfstoff als
erstes zunächst und das konzept zur
priorisierung da geht es darum für wen
sollen die ersten impfung bereit
gehalten werden
danach geht es aber um das konzept auch
unsere dosen zur führung von einzusetzen
und da stellt sich natürlich auch
logistische fragen in welchen
impfzentren macht man dass die schiller
personen kann man gleichzeitig impfen
unter beibehaltung der entsprechenden
abstand zu regeln wie wird die logistik
der transporte impfstoffdosen geschaffen
darum wird gerade gearbeitet mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren